[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti per capirsi non
so chi dei due sia il lestofante di
sicuro a dispetto del saio il monaco
ossia il banchiere e lui e vorrei
sottolineare la ragione per cui abbiamo
scelto questo frame questo pezzo del
film di nanni moretti perché ci richiama
l'importanza delle parole e dunque
proviamo a riflettere in partenza sul
significato e meglio ancora
sull'etimologia della parola che nel
titolo di questo appuntamento che sta
per tracotanza libris tracotanza se
guardiamo le l'etimologia latina ultra
cogitans colui che pensa lontano colui
che vede oltre colui che esplora una
frontiera ma anche colui che pensa
eccessivamente bene di sé e allora
partirei così fabio ci scuserete se ci
diamo del tu ma tra lestofanti c'è un
minimo di dimestichezza e partire
proprio da questo se ti viene a mente un
uomo che potrebbe impersonare il
concetto di tracotanza oggi chi è
allora forse lo conoscete questo
biondino che sta dietro le mie spalle io
vi chiederei di alzare la mano ecco
vorrei che alzasse la mano chi ritiene
che donald trump sia tracotante non
abbiate pure alzare la mano le sberle
non dovrebbero arrivare quelle di nanni
moretti
grazie allora per voi che non vedete
circa metà della sala ha alzato la mano
donald trump è superbo donald trump e
arrogante donald trump è villano e poi
questo lo dico così tre di noi è pure
antipatico almeno a me sta antipatico
però donald trump non è tracotante
tracotante e quello che guarda oltre
quello che ha una visione della visione
del mondo che verrà che ci vuole
anticipare il futuro e abbiate pazienza
lui è difficile immaginarlo in questa in
questa categoria forse all'altro
pezzetto che è quello di essere pieno di
sé pro no non basta essere in acqua per
essere un pesce la finanza la finanza
paolo eva rima con tracotanza finanza la
finanziaria l'ex manager che era
sicuramente tracotante nel senso di
visionaria abbiamo detto che trump no
però proviamo a pensare alla liaison
link finanza tracotanza quelle risposte
semplice la finanza e tracotante e ve lo
racconto te lo racconto con
una storia che è partita romantica della
finanza che voleva fare una cosa bella
voleva rendere ricchi poveri con i mutui
subprime quelli che poi sono diventati i
mutui spazzatura
cosa è successo e questa cosa
me l'ha raccontata bill dico con le sue
parole bill bill quando aveva 20 anni e
faceva il pendolare tra a berkeley tra
l'università di california e telegraph
per chi non conosce la california è una
strada molto vicino all'università dove
è nato il 68 uno dei luoghi cult dove
noè è davvero a rischio il 68 non erano
proprio per o magari no
un pochino lo si ricorda allora passava
il tempo a farsi e disfarsi la sua bella
coda di cavallo da da figlio dei fiori a
leggere i testi di matematica
dell'università e poi a salire e
scendere da una cassetta di frutta che
gli serviva per declamare e urlare i
suoi discorsi che erano essenzialmente
contro il capitalismo e contro i padroni
io l'ho conosciuto
trent'anni dopo trent'anni dopo nel 98
quando vivevamo tutti e due a boston nel
massachusetts e lui mi ha detto la
seguente cosa mi ha detto ce l'ho fatta
sono andato oltre
vedi fabio grazie all'immigrazione c'è
la crescita demografica negli stati
uniti 56 per cento all'anno quindi c'è
sempre più bisogno di case essendoci
sempre più bisogno di case di queste
case che vedete dietro le mie spalle ci
sarà un prezzo sempre più alte delle
case se c'è un prezzo sempre più alto
delle case le banche l'hanno capito e
hanno iniziato a bere mutua che i soldi
non ce li hai e ci hanno dato il mutuo
per la casa e magari anche il muto per
l'arredamento e per la televisione
abbiamo risolto il problema della
povertà in america e poi con le sue
certezze assolute
mi ha anche detto abbiamo anche risolto
il problema dei risparmiatori perché
magari un mutuo può andar male sono
scappa quei soldi ma l'insieme dei mutui
mondo nei quali i prezzi delle case
salgono non può che andare bene e allora
mettiamo insieme tanti mutui erogati li
facciamo comperare dai rischi armatori
da chi ha già il denaro li mettiamo dei
specie di salsicciotti cose grande con
cento mille diecimila muti dentro e
abbiamo una forma meravigliosa di
risparmio sicuro e garantito
beh sembrava una sorta di panacea
sembrava robin hood che era comparso a
wall street facendo abbastanza
complicata da credere abbiamo visto poi
come è andata a me questo racconto fa
veniva mente un passo della genesi
bibbia e chiedo alla regia se riesce
mentre parliamo fabio io se riesce a
cercare un immagine della torre di
babele perché chiedo la torre di babele
un'immagine della torre di babele perché
sta cercando ci vuole un momento di
tempo è una babele anche il web e quindi
ci saranno pure dei percorsi di ricerca
e e chiedo alla regia se ne seleziona in
modo particolare l'ultima immagine cioè
quella a stampa in bianco e nero perché
in quella immagine
fabio io ci vedo o meglio richiamo un
fattore e cioè quello dell'impazzimento
delle lingue tutti quelli che lavoravano
per costruire questa astrazione cioè
questo tentativo di andare verso il
cielo verso gli altri
ad un certo punto hanno smarrito la
lingua comune è un elemento molto
specifico di questa stagione e della
stagione della finanza e poi osservo che
la torre questa torre in modo
particolare a una base stretta si
sviluppa in verticale molto slanciata
rischio crollo e ti propongo questa
metafora anzi questa allegoria insomma
questa somma di metafore
perché è esattamente quello che è
avvenuto nel vostro mondo con
l'impazzimento delle lingue e con un
sistema che poi non reggeva più è
crollato
purtroppo funziona la metafora funziona
perché io non so se quella base fosse
larga o stretta paolo ma sopra ci hanno
costruito troppa roba detta
semplicemente anno gli ha preso la mano
il mutuo subprime e quindi anziché farne
tanti ne ha fatti tanti tantissimi
troppi ed è venuta una torre alta alta
alta una torre che ha iniziato a
scricchiolare e sullo scricchiolio
purtroppo funziona ancora di più la
metafora perché esattamente come nel
mito del della torre di babele non ci si
è più capiti l'un l'altro
beh immaginate quei risparmiatori che
avevano investito in questi grossi
salsicciotti che avevano dentro tutti i
mutui ha iniziato a dire ma questa cosa
è molto alta scricchiola ma siamo
davvero sicuri che siano così tranquilli
questi questi salsicciotti e hanno
iniziato a provare ad aprirli a guardare
dentro non hanno capito niente perché
era un gran casino dentro quei quei
salsicciotti e quindi l'uno non capiva
più l'altro e così è crollata è crollata
la torre sono
crollate le case e questo è stato il
risultato no dei dei mutui subprime
quindi sono rimasti senza casa quelli
che dove diventa ricchi con la casa sono
rimasti senza soldi quelli che doveva
the hunter ricchi coi soldi forse bill è
rimasto con qualche milione in tasca lui
sì la gente comune no quello che abbiamo
sperimentato è una forma di tracotanza
oltre ogni limite e oltre ogni
regolamentazione
una esperienza che abbiamo fatto in
questi anni infatti è la difficoltà di
dare un regime ad un fenomeno globale
tipicamente globale come la finanza non
esistendo un assetto istituzionale che
sia al pari della globalità e
conseguentemente la finanza
anche dopo la grande crisi anche dopo il
crollo di wall street e di lheman
brothers
per la verità ha trovato delle modalità
autoreggenti ma non dei veri
interlocutori nelle istituzioni allora
dato questo come mio pensiero però ti
domando esiste una dimensione
applicativa di una finanza tra mille
virgolette è buona c'è ci porti un buon
esempio guarda ca te lo chiedo perché tu
l'anno passato ha scritto un libro il
cui titolo è quanto mai significativo e
di cui abbiamo discusso insieme e che
parla della possibilità di trovare un
banchiere perbene no vero
la risposta è ovviamente sì ed è
ovviamente una scalata dell'everest
dimostrarlo
come diceva come diceva prima alessandro
cecchi paone oggi il banchiere
lestofante per per definizione e te lo
provo a raccontare velo prova a
raccontare questa volta con una storia
del 2018 non del 2007
questa immagine che vedete dietro le
vostre spalle è un'immagine antica ma
viva è il pon di gare un ponte su tre
livelli che fa parte dell'acquedotto
romano in francia in provenza vedete
tanta acqua sotto acqua che scorre ecco
la finanza di questi anni è stata una
finanza dopo la crisi piena di liquidità
la liquidità è stata enorme ma per certi
versi non bastava la liquidità no questa
enorme massa di denaro che è stata messa
in circolo delle banche centrali perché
le liquidità arriva passa e va via
mentre le imprese hanno bisogno di un
qualcosa di stabile quindi bisognava
trasformare quella liquidità in un
qualcosa di stabile che stesse che
stesse sopra come questo ponte questo
acquedotto così ben diverso dal torre di
babele in finanza si chiama capitale c'è
una gran differenza tra il denaro il
capitale il denaro la liquidità arriverà
il capitale se arriva c'è uno può
investire 1 se non lo usa male solo usa
male può anche bruciarlo ma c'è e non
scompare nel momento difficile
cosa è successo è successo che in
america e in asia dopo due anni sono
riusciti a trasformare la liquidità in
capitale in inghilterra in germania due
anni dalla crisi famosa in inghilterra
in germania ci hanno messo cinque sei
anni siamo arrivati al 2013 2014 in
italia in italia ci abbia messo di più
ma oggi ci siamo riusciti
oggi un insieme di interventi
legislativi tipo i vantaggi fiscali sui
pirri piani individuali di risparmio
si vuole trasformare in capitale delle
imprese non quotate
la propria liquidità oggi i fondi
private equity che è una parola
difficile per dire semplicemente sono
disponibili ad investire in una piccola
media azienda anche se non è quotata
oggi la possibilità di quotare al lime
che la borsa minore italiana anche un
impresa piccola un'impresa che non si
può permettere
i costi della quotazione beh questo è
riuscito a trasformare la liquidità in
potenziale capitale faccio un esempio
una storia quella loro il di oggi allora
la storia di bill di oggi non ha nome
inglese ha un nome italiano un nome di
uomo è un nome di donna che sono
fratello e sorella
si chiamano sergio e lucia e è la storia
di due imprenditori del caldo e del
freddo quindi se volete un settore non
estremamente innovativo ha un suo
livello di innovazione ma saldamente
ancorato nel nell'economia reale
loro sono stati bravissimi in questi
dieci anni di crisi perchè sono stati
sempre attenti a non fare il passo
troppo lungo quindi andare all'estero si
ma quanto basta per evitare di essere
una trappola finanziaria innovare
investire in innovazione si ma quanto
basta per non appesantirsi troppo col
denaro chiesto alle banche hanno le
braccia robuste le mani piene di calle
per contenuto i freni non hanno tirati
perché proprio non volevano andare oltre
quando ho raccontato queste cose a
sergio lucia
io ho visto il senso di vuoto davanti
perché mi dicevano fammi capire tu mi
stai dicendo che io non ho più il
vincolo non ho più il vincolo del
capitale cioè posso con la mia storia
avere capitale vostro capitale di terzi
che accetta il mio governo pur non
essendo una società quotata
e stata una riunione difficile quando
dieci giorni dopo mi ha telefonato solo
sergio e mi ha telefonato ha iniziato a
[Musica]
parlarmi di mercati nuovi per la sua
azienda è iniziato a parlarmi di una
rivoluzione dal punto di vista proprio
di innovazione tecnologica del quale non
l'avevo mai sentito parlare
e poi mi ha detto tante altre cose ea un
certo punto per tornare a questo potere
di andare oltre io ho detto a sergio ma
sergio ti rendi conto che tu sei andato
oltre sei andato oltre te stesso e lui è
stato zitto e mi ha detto no io credo
che finalmente sono riuscito ad andare
oltre ai miei sogni
noi ci fermiamo qui
sergio e lucia avevano un campo avevano
anche un sacco pieno di semi se l'erano
tenuto stretto non sapevano neanche bene
cosa farne di questi semi perché gli
mancava l'acqua poi l'immagine di fondi
garci viene proprio a parlare della
necessità e della preziosità e della
rarità dell'acqua
i soldi sono un concime da sempre basta
che siano usati bene grazie a voi tutti
per l'attenzione e buon proseguimento
grazie grazie
[Musica]